thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday it's Halloween Eve so happy
Halloween Eve everybody Pookie's
freaking out over the fan she does not
like that
we turned the fan on and she's like
she's looking
she's like what what
you want to go up here and see it she
wants to go up and visit the fan no
we're not you're not gonna visit the fan
no no no
maybe really
I can't do anything about it
it does that she's looking at it
it does that it's a fan
you got to do the show okay
she's always the same yeah it's [ __ ]
funny man maybe that maybe that night we
did the show and uh and we thought that
she was seeing demons maybe it was just
the fan that she didn't like it's moving
yeah she's crying about it because the
fan is spinning and it's wobbling a
little bit it's gonna be okay don't
worry about the single ball
oh no
ridiculous she doesn't
like it not one stop that dick it's
gonna be okay yeah it's gonna be okay
she's waking out yeah that's really
funny well sometimes we turn it on and
she doesn't react like that
it's paranormal
it's very adorable yeah anyway yeah so
yeah like I said it's Halloween Eve and
uh you know periodically you'll hear a
little crying back
[Music]
you're walking around
[Laughter]
I know
that shit's amazing
yeah
get rid of that [ __ ]
okay she's like don't she's like don't
blow me off I feel like it all right so
anyway yeah so it's Halloween Eve so uh
I think we had to watch a movie Friday
night like right after the Sidetrack
show
and so you know we were a little bit
inebriated and I was like well I don't
want it and I was tired so I was like
well I don't want to watch anything too
complicated uh so I was like oh I
remembered that this movie
um was free to watch and also I've seen
it a bunch of times so it was like you
know easier and also it's Halloween
themed because it's actually like set
around Halloween and there is like
Halloween dance at the end of it uh so I
figured we'll kind of like talk about
this one briefly before talking about
some other stuff although it seems that
that Pokey just wants to
she's trying to come up
what you coming up
never seen her do this well actually she
didn't know she did it that she did it
on that one show yeah and I think it was
but like I said sometimes we turn the
fan on and it doesn't seem to bother her
but like sometimes you turn it on and
she like starts freaking out she's like
I don't like it turn it off so I don't
know sometimes oh [ __ ] that was almost a
disaster yeah waiting to happen
yeah
but yeah so uh so this is a movie that
came out back in 1985. I think I
probably saw this movie a million times
like on cable just because it seemed
like it was always on and this was a
movie that in case you didn't know this
was I think Jim Carrey's first
movie roller I don't know if it was like
his first movie role but his first like
main like lead role uh because I think
this was even before yeah this was
definitely before uh because he was on a
Living Color right that TV series I'm
pretty sure it was before that I think
he was only like in his 20s uh even
though he's playing a high school
student I think he was only 23 or
something like that so this was like the
first movie that he was in and for some
reason like I don't know
there's like some um no stop it don't
tear up the books oh my God she was just
like being a real brat today yeah just
okay she tears that up well that's I've
told you before that's why I put the
show okay I put okay I put the old books
on the bottom because she like why are
you acting his way yeah she's bad she's
being a real yeah she's being a real
brat yeah and like I was um before the
show I was brushing her and she tried to
grab the brush and ended up grabbing my
finger instead so she got my finger yeah
yeah Louie said seen this one a couple
of times yeah it's kind of like I don't
know if I'd call it it's more like a
comedy but with horror elements it's
kind of like a teen sex comedy really
but with a Vampire
um so basically what happens in this one
it's kind of like one of those you know
a lot of those movies in the 80s were
like the whole like plot was it's
centered around somebody trying to lose
their virginity which I feel like was
probably most of the comedies from the
80s
um yeah this is one of those but like I
said it's with a fire Lauren Hutton
actually plays the vampire and I
actually really uh really like her in
this and for whatever reason
um a lot of lines from this movie like
stuck with me and also like the [ __ ]
songs are total ear worms uh I just
watched the movie on Friday night and
I've had the two the main theme song and
the one they do like during the dance
off I've had those two songs like stuck
in my head ever since then uh slasher
friends that this movie is an underrated
classic there is the you know what to
for some reason like the funniest line
to me that it stuck with me for all of
these years because I saw this movie a
bunch of times like back in the late 80s
but I haven't seen it like for many many
years probably since then but for
whatever reason like a line that always
stuck with me was when
um after like Jim Carrey first goes to
the vampire's house and like he doesn't
remember anything that happened but then
like the next day he said he's telling
Lord and Hutton that he had a dream and
he's like
um he's like you know these little foil
pouches that you put a straw in there
and there's like fruit juice like a
Capri Sun but I guess he couldn't say
that and she's like uh-huh and he's like
last night I dreamed I was one of those
because she was like for whatever reason
they're like well I just made me laugh
and it's like I still remember it like
to this day
um I kind of feel like
I don't know like you you didn't like
this no I didn't like this movie you
know like this movie now had you seen
this back in the 80s uh I don't think so
this is one of the 80sest 80s movies and
I had forgotten how 80s it was because
like I said the last time I saw it was
probably in the late 80s or the early
90s and I hadn't seen it again since
then and I was like holy [ __ ] this is
like one of the most 80s movies I mean
everything is like the [ __ ] they were
wearing
um the [ __ ] Boutique that uh Jim
Carrey's girlfriend Robin works at I was
like oh my God I remember mall stores it
looked exactly like that all the clothes
like the music the [ __ ] layout of
Lauren Hutton's Mansion it was just oh
my God it was like so [ __ ] 80s and
then there was like the the requisite
scene of you know it's all those movies
like in the 80s that were set in
California and it was always kind of
like the Suburban kids like and they
just were going down to Hollywood that's
the crazy place and so they would kind
of like drive around and it's like oh
there's a lady with like a silver dress
on like walking a lion and like like all
this other kind of crazy [ __ ] and like
all the [ __ ] neon and whatever and
then they go to that [ __ ]
um then they go to that uh like that
hookup bar that's all like phone themed
like you can call the other tables like
all the tables have numbers on them and
it's like if you see somebody across the
thing that looks good you call their
table there
right and those well yeah and it's like
and all the phones are like shaped like
lips and I was like oh my God this is
the most and then like some of the decor
was like big giant Foams like with
buttons on it and stuff and I was like
sitting there going holy [ __ ] was this a
real place or probably not I think not
that might well I don't know I was
because I was thinking that to myself
while I was watching it because I had
forgotten like I said just how like over
the top 80s this was and I had forgotten
about that bar and I was just kind of
like I imagine that was probably made
for the movie but I could see a place
like that existing back in the 80s I
mean it seemed very much like that
oh my God not bad she's so distracted
on purpose
yeah yeah she's mad because we're gonna
pay attention to her
come here
yeah Louis said isn't Jim Carrey the
last virgin in town yeah that's well
that's kind of like the running gag is
that Lauren Hutton who plays a 400 year
old vampire
her thing is that every so often she has
to feed from a male virgin and it's like
a whole thing like she has to do it like
three times or whatever and she always
had and she has to take the blood from
the inner thigh too
she's wrestling yeah are you wrestling
she's like is that bad that's why I'm
bad she's bad
uh oh Daddy's biting you
um but yeah so she has to do that and
the running joke is that I don't know if
like she's lived in La for a long time
or she just moved there or something
like that but that's kind of like the
joke is that you know there's no virgins
anymore like they can't find one which
is weird because even when I was a kid
when I saw this movie like his two dorky
friends I'm like those two guys are
clearly virgins too like like what why
did she uh just hone in on uh Mark which
is Jim Carrey's character name but I
mean the other two I guess were dorkier
looking and then maybe I don't know but
the thing about it is like and I had
forgotten that Clevon little was in this
too like he plays her uh
servant I guess
um and he's there's like a running gag
too that it's uh that he's like gay so
there's a bunch of jokes that um he's
always like in her closet and like
stealing her clothes and like she's
always like knocking his name's
Sebastian and then she's always like
knocking on the closet door and then
like he opens the door and like has her
scarf on or something and then like he
makes jokes about I came out of the
closet like 200 years ago and all this
other kind of stuff so there's like a
lot of
um gay humor in this which probably I
mean it seems kind of like I don't know
it seems like ever so slightly
homophobic uh because and especially too
and I know that was kind of like a thing
in the 80s like everybody was kind of
like you know it was just kind of a joke
they even have a thing where uh like in
the weird phone bar there's
um you know one of the dorky kids like
gets called and goes over there and like
he thinks it's a hot woman and then it's
a dude so you know that's kind of like a
classic kind of 80s joke from this kind
of movie and then I had actually
forgotten about this scene too
um and I was like a little bit surprised
but there's a scene where like I said
the vampire has to suck the blood out of
the inner thigh and rather than doing
the normal thing like a girlfriend would
and saying hey can I see your inner
thigh like I think something might be
the matter with you or something she
tried she tells his two stupid friends
they're like well she's like why don't
you try to look at his inner thigh like
while you're in the locker room or
whatever and like see if he has bite
marks there like to make sure that it's
a vampire that we're dealing with or
whatever so there's kind of like this
long extended sequence where they're
trying like to maneuver around and like
look at his crotch like without him
knowing about it and then finally they
get so sick of like trying to do it that
one of them just grabs him like in the
shower and then he's just kind of like
look at his crowns look at his cry the
other guy's looking and he doesn't he
can't see because he has soap in his
eyes and then like one of the other guys
there's like fangs in the shower [ __ ] in
the shower and then I was just like holy
crap and then like the next scene is
like the two guys talk about how
humiliating it is like everyone thinks
we're gay and then he said something
about reenacting a prison rape scene and
I was like whoa I didn't remember that
going there but yeah so uh so yeah it's
funny
the movie Just from the very beginning
is over the top silly it is very silly
like I said and I just couldn't handle
it I was just like I said it's not
really it has like a vampire in it yeah
but it's not a vampire movie it's not a
vampire movie really I mean it is
because it kind of like plays with those
tropes but it's more kind of along the
lines of like love at first bite or
Dracula dead and Loving It or something
like that you know what I mean it's
actually just more in common with a
bunch of teen comedies and stuff yeah
it's a teen sex comedy yeah it's it's
but with a Vampire like with that angle
to it which you know it was like and
also I thought this was interesting too
and I don't know if they were
homaging that this specifically I think
they probably were but like I said
there's a part at the end like near the
end where they do
um there's a Halloween dance at the
school and they all go and there's like
a dance off between
um you know Jim Carrey's girlfriend
Robin and the vampire Lauren Hutton and
they're trying to like and it's like
this whole choreographed dance I mean
it's like really really funny and it's
like has this really earworm of a song
but it reminded me of that scene in
Greece you know what I mean like where
uh Cha-Cha comes in and is like trying
to dance like Danny away from Sandy so
I'm wondering if that was like what they
were homaging
in this here's the thing this is the way
I always saw these kind of movies
retroactively like once they aged and
you look back at them
and you see how much they had in common
with old school variety shows yeah Hee
Haw yeah where they're trying to show
you a bunch of Comedy situations over
and you know what I mean in some kind of
a sequence and they're using kind of a
storyline to thread them together
but it's kind of like the comedy skits
really were written first and then the
story was written afterwards so it was
kind of like yeah it kind of ends up
being like
a variety show yeah which is that's what
Cannonball Ron was and [ __ ] like that it
was a variety show you know and [ __ ]
well yeah Cannonball Run was like that
smoking the band it was kind of like
that yeah it's a well it's like a bunch
of bits it's a bunch of bits like
drawing together drawing together with a
sword yeah which I feel like a lot of
comedies or maybe not so much nowadays I
kind of feel like they're different now
but and and internet killed that all
right yeah so these don't exist anymore
and probably will never really come back
the closest thing I've ever seen to
something like this in the modern world
are these uh chick flicks you know like
[ __ ] yeah the girl that [ __ ] she
thought where was she was in what was
the one I actually liked it fat girl
[ __ ] thought she was in a rom-com oh
yeah what the [ __ ] was the name of that
it was actually a pretty good one I
liked that one actually well I liked
that one because I don't usually like
chick flicks but I liked that one
because it was sort of making fun of
chick flicks but also kind of was a
chick flick at the same time and so I
thought it was kind of cute that they
were like playing with all the troops
and everything and it actually it was
like kind of male friendly yeah because
it was self-aware self-aware was kind of
like goofing on Chick-fil-A right so
you're like good yeah it was goofing on
female fantasy right you know that's why
that's why I thought it was funny yeah
it was good I just remember the name of
that
I'll think of it in a minute had that
we've reviewed it that heavy weight that
heavy girl she's cute but she's fat and
she was she's a comedian yeah and she
was the
she woke up and she thought she was in a
rom-com yeah everything everything was
just like a super perfect yeah yeah I
liked that one because like I said if
you think about romantic comedies and
this movie is kind of has that as well
particularly like from the 80s and stuff
I haven't seen any like brilla recent
ones so I'm not really sure if they're
still like this but a lot of Schumer was
it Amy Schumer no no no no no
um [ __ ] uh no it wasn't Amy Shield what
the [ __ ] is her name it's not uh it's
not Rebel Wilson is it might have been
huh no she looks like yeah I think it
might have been Rebel Wilson yeah what
was the name of that movie oh God damn
it just another romantic comedy no it
was um [ __ ] I can even I can see the
title screen I'm just like I can't like
think of the [ __ ] name
it was that was one of the better movies
of that year it was actually like I said
I was surprised by like how much I liked
it yeah it was like really funny but the
thing about it like I said well when you
think about a lot of rom-coms this is
probably the reason why I didn't like
them is um and I've seen other people
point this out too so it's not like it's
my original idea or anything but
um with just a few tree a few tweaks
like McCarthy no no I think it was the
same right I'm pretty sure it was Rebel
yeah I think it was
um but with just a few tweaks a lot of
rom-coms like classic rom-coms could
totally be horror movies I mean because
a lot of the setups for them like if you
wrote that out as a setup like oh we're
gonna set this up as a rom-com I'm like
that sounds like the setup of a horror
movie though like it's I feel like
they're really really similar but yeah
like [ __ ] that happens in uh rom-coms
and a lot of people point this out you
know the very classic like Christmas
rom-com Like Love Actually
that scene where um where um do like
dude from The Walking Dead like comes to
that girl's
that woman's uh door like with the signs
like on the day she gets married or
something like that I'm like dude that
is stalker Behavior knock that [ __ ] off
but they but they're kind of like
romantic that's it and it was Rebel
Wilson it was horrible okay yeah 2019.
yeah grafter said Rebel Wilson is skinny
now I thought she yeah I thought she
lost a bunch of weight yeah I haven't
seen her in a while and uh if that was
actually isn't it romantic is actually a
good movie a dude could watch that
because it's [ __ ] funny yeah I
thought it was all right yeah it because
it's goofing on rom-coms and female
fantasy but it's not
it's not goofing on an in mean-spirited
ways well that's what I liked about it
is that it totally works as a rom-com
but it totally works as like a parody of
a rom-com too so that's why I thought it
was funny because like I don't like
rom-coms yeah uh you know they get on my
nerves but um I don't even I don't even
like a lot of Comedy well I don't know
if I want to say that but it's like I
have a very particular weird sense of
humor so
I don't know like a lot of comedies that
I see I don't think are all that funny
um but
it's I don't know and a lot of my
favorite movies are not comedies like
it's really really hard for me to like
see a comedy that I really really
dig so so the fact that I thought that
one was funny that I thought was like
good
but I think like I said I kind of feel
like in the 80s you had in rom-coms you
had in teen sex comedies you had stuff
like that it still seemed like and this
one had that too even though it kind of
acknowledged it a little bit but the way
that it kind of um I just always thought
it was funny like the um I don't this
emphasis on virginity that was in like
so many of the 80s movies like it seemed
really retrograde to me like even in the
80s I guess but maybe it was something
that was like on a lot of people I mean
obviously a lot of people went to see
these movies so it must have resonated
but I just thought it was like a such a
strange
she's hot
holy [ __ ] it doesn't look like the same
[ __ ] woman you got hot very hot
doesn't even look like the same [ __ ]
one yeah it makes a difference well yeah
it makes a big difference
Jenny Watson first time I'm
participating I love you both oh thank
you okay we love you too thank you first
time first time participating long time
lurker first time commenter I guess but
uh but yeah so yeah there's so much
emphasis on virginity and this one I
don't know if it if it's almost like
making fun of that a little bit I kind
of feel like it is which maybe makes it
a little bit ahead of its time I don't
know but because the whole plot point is
she needs to find a virgin like to make
her because otherwise she'll get old
like she needs mail I don't remember if
they say like how often she has to like
drink male virgin blood I'm assuming
it's not that often because she's just
like come out of a hyper sleep or
whatever the [ __ ] and she's going around
looking and it's like this big deal and
you know she only has like three days
before whatever and she has to do it
but uh you know and then the whole thing
too is about Jim Carrey and he has a
girlfriend named Robin but she won't
have sex with him because he's friend
zoned he's yeah I mean they're going out
but well the thing about it like I kind
of get like I didn't like her character
to be honest like I thought she was like
a stick in the mud and kind of like a
[ __ ] and everything although he was a
douche gotta say so they were kind of
made for each other's asking if I know
Voltaire yeah no Voltaire I was friends
with his ex-wife
Italian
yeah he's um I don't know him I've met
him once like we had a club or whatever
but yeah I watch his uh yeah he's the
Martha Stewart yeah I've only met him
once but I I was like good friends with
his ex-wife I like his Gothic homemaking
series on YouTube it's super cute
actually he just posted one the other
day like spooky [ __ ] around New York
City like stores and bars and that kind
of stuff it was like pretty cool but he
always does because he has an apartment
in New York City and he does like
various like decorations and stuff and
he does some Halloween hunting and stuff
like that too like because he knows that
other that girl
um from Kansas City uh Jade the laborer
that his thing I watch like all the
Halloween decorating and stuff and
whenever he's in Kansas City like they
go Halloween shopping together because
they're like friends because I think her
husband like used to own a bar that he
played at or something like that
I went offline for some reason really
yeah we're still on right I'm yeah it's
still it's still green okay it's still
green yeah weird
but yeah but I was gonna say so his
girlfriend I like okay I I get where I
get where girlfriend is coming from okay
because she's like he wants to get laid
fine they're at the drive-in or wherever
he drives an ice cream truck and you
know he's a virgin she's a virgin she's
like I don't really want to lose my
virginity in an ice cream truck which I
get that I mean if any I mean just
because it's real uncomfortable one
thing
um but two it just you don't really want
that to be your first experience like in
an ice cream truck
um but there is kind of like a funny
scene where after she kind of like
shoots him down uh you know not wanting
to have sex in the ice cream truck like
he gets out and then there's like I are
they're at a drive-in theater I think
and then there's like all these cars and
all the cars like start bouncing and
stuff like that like it's like rubbing
it in that he can't get any but I was
like at least spring for a hotel room I
mean he's got an ice cream truck he's
got a job and stuff like that maybe
she'd be more like you know maybe she'd
be more receptive but I don't know I
just kind of feel like his whole thing
about well my girlfriend won't have sex
with me in the front seat of an ice
cream truck so I'm gonna go like pick up
some Rancho some random from a bar
somewhere and like he does that and then
she like gets mad and breaks up with him
but then like she forgives him like
almost immediately which I thought was
funny I was like you could have all kind
of diseases now buddy well as it turned
out he did have a disease he turned into
a vampire but you know but actually she
like um she had sex with him before the
third bite so he I guess turned back
into a human because I think that's how
that works which I think isn't that how
Dracula worked now that I'm thinking
about it like he had to bite you like so
many times like he it wasn't just like a
one and done type situation like he came
in yeah because I think when he was uh
when he was I think of the old story
feeding off Lucy he had to keep coming
back and then like then she eventually
died like of a disease and then she came
back as a vampire so maybe it was that
but so I think it was like the same kind
of thing so I think they were homoging
that although I remember in that
original movie with you know with Bella
Lugosi it never really mentions him
feeding her any of his blood then later
on they're showing scenes in other
movies where if the vampire bites his
own wrist and makes you drink some of
his blood you'll become a vampire
eventually or like a thrall like
Renfield yeah how much do they give you
I guess
yeah because I was under the impression
now it's been a while since I've read
Dracula um you know it's probably from
the book well see I thought it was
because I thought he gave Mina some of
his blood but see the thing about it
though is that I thought Dracula because
he didn't like give Lucy enemy's blood
right he just came in like over
successive nights however many nights it
was three nights I want to say four
nights however long I've never read the
book and um okay well that yeah that's
like you can't really judge from that
because the movies are like yeah take
wild Liberties wild Liberties um there
most of them are based on the stage play
like the early ones are mostly based and
I don't know what was mentioned in the
stage play and here's the thing the
vampire thing
is a reboot it's a rip-off okay
the original is the stragoy and the
stragoy could do all kinds of [ __ ] okay
and that was the original story
vampire was kind of a ripoff of a
[ __ ] stragoy astragoy was
a
vampire
it could have sex with living women and
have children with them it could have
sex with vampire women and have living
children with them or vampire children
it could have sex with a dead body and
it would give birth to an undead [ __ ]
vampire there was all kinds of weird
[ __ ] they could do they had families
and then they were Sorcerers on top of
that they they had all kinds of
different abilities so I'm pretty pretty
sure that the vampires
vampires came from Starboy and a lot of
the stuff that
Dracula is supposed to be doing in that
book
with stuff that struggle I could do
but then a lot of [ __ ] that struggle I
could do was left out
so it kind of became a separate thing
yeah that's my understanding of it based
on my reading of this throw boy
well yeah that's kind of like an initial
but the thing about it like a lot of the
vampire troops are not necessarily from
Bram Stoker but
um because there had been like you know
uh Sheridan lafanu wrote carmilla which
had some of the same stuff in it but a
lot of that came from folklore yeah but
it's just that they kind of like
gathered it I kind of feel like Bram
Stoker sort of like codified like it all
into one thing yeah it was like really
popular kind of making a new creature in
a way out of these pieces but the pieces
I think are mostly coming from stragoy
stories yeah all right yeah Louis said
he gave Mina his blood to control her
and have a mental link with her yeah I
thought that he gave me Mina his blood
because I was gonna say though that
um because I think in the original book
he was kind of more portrayed as like a
plague type character because he didn't
give Lucy his blood but after Lucy died
she came back as a vampire like he just
like drained her over successive nights
or whatever and then she just kept
popping out her coffin and like eating
babies and whatnot so she so you don't
like
so back in the old stories like you just
if you died from a vampire drinking your
blood then you would become a vampire
whether they gave you their blood or not
which like I said you can see the um the
problem that arises there is that
eventually everybody in the world would
be vampires and I think that somebody
actually did the math on that like how
long it would take not very long at all
uh for everybody to be vampires so I
think that's why later on they added the
thing where you have to do a blood
exchange like to make somebody a vampire
and it's more like a special thing
because if everybody that a vampire
killed also turned into a vampire then
pretty soon you would be up to your
armpits in vampires and the vampires
wouldn't have any else to snack on so
you know so there's that
but um but yeah uh slasher Fred said
there's a scene in the movie where
during the final confrontation where
they try to do the old crucifix and the
Countess laughs and says it only works
in the movies yeah but see immediately
after that though like one of the other
guys like holds out like a candle like
on a stick or a torch or something like
that it seems like fire on the other
hand and I was like well if you guys are
scared of fire why do you have like
[ __ ] why do you have candles all over
the [ __ ] place you know what I mean
it's the modern day it's the 20th
century you have electricity you don't
really need Louie says I don't think
Starboy were ever human
um I don't know because they can have
children that look very human and half
human maybe they weren't human I don't
know
um I had to go back and look I don't
think a Starboy was ever human but they
could create human children
or human-like children
a good movie there's only one Starboy
movie that I know of and that's [ __ ]
blood vessel it's real good guys could
watch it it's just kind of newer well
then I I think Guillermo del Toro did
one did he
was it was that a movie or a series I
can't remember I haven't seen it but
okay well if if the stragoy is really
where the vampire came from
maybe you could read stragoy
[ __ ] folklore into saying that
Dracula may have been the child of a
strong boy
oh I like that okay
because they could have a strong boy
could have sex with a living woman
and give birth to a child that looked
like a human and it was alive it never
died but it was born astragoy a born a
vampire alive
and didn't have to die to become one
although they could do that too
they could die and then come back so
maybe Dracula was that a child of a
stragoy
which would make him a strong boy I
think or no that would make a vampire I
guess
I think the oldest I think the oldest
reference to a [ __ ] vampire is a is a
yupier I think and it probably just
means vampire and if I remember
correctly the one of the oldest mentions
of vampire was in
the [ __ ] a letter that some ship
captain was
send it some somewhere else to the
company he worked for and he was just
calling lawyers a bunch of vampires that
they were sucking him dry
so there was it so and this was a long
time ago but that's the oldest I think
physical evidence of that word
and it was talking about lawyers calling
them vampires
so and I think that might have been
1500s
it's been around a long time
well yeah it's a very very old concept
yeah I mean anything like that I kind of
feel like because
humans are humans and humans are afraid
of death then you're always gonna I
don't think it's that weird that pretty
much every culture has a concept like a
vampire something of like a blood well
and like a corpse that's coming back
because originally uh most vampire
stories had to do with because
originally it wasn't you know nowadays
people like vampire it's just like an
undead thing that like drinks anybody
but um you know it's just whatever but
uh you know back in the old days it was
just kind of like it was your relative
you had to worry about them just coming
back and like attacking your family
specifically like it was your relative
and they would come back and get you and
I think even in the um even in that
Mario Baba uh Anthology movie that had a
story about that in there where like
they and a bunch of stories that I read
when I was a kid like old school
vampires they were always more worried
about oh if you're a relative died it's
like oh we have to bury them and like
[ __ ] put a stake through their heart
and cut their head off and [ __ ] like
that so they don't come back and get us
specifically I just think it's hilarious
that the oldest historical reference to
vampire is a dude writing about [ __ ]
lawyers
that are sucking him dry Zach says I'd
love to see a movie about a lawyer who's
an actual vampire you there's gotta be
one
there's movies about everything
seriously
I was scrolling through [ __ ] movies
the other day and I saw a movie called
killer donut okay it's like there has to
be a lawyer vampire somebody must have
done that somebody
slasher Fred said in the original 1931
film Dracula it's Renfield who visits
the count and in the novel it's John
Parker who visits Dracula yeah that was
one of the things that
because in the original book
Renfield didn't go to Dracula's place
first did he I thought that was like a
later Edition like a later Edition from
the player for the movies so many
different well that's what I'm saying I
can't remember because it's been so long
since I read the novel but I like the
addition of like Renfield being the
first uh you know solicitor or you know
proper like the guy that was going to
set up the property and him going there
and the Dracula [ __ ] him up and then
that happening and then them sending
Harkers the replacement but I think in
the book
in the book wasn't Renfield just like a
random dude that he just like came
across it's like hey you're my minion
now or I can't remember like I can't
keep any of that [ __ ] it's been such a
long time well and like I said it's been
told so many times and everybody changes
it a little bit there's a video I've
never yeah there's a video that shows
all the different
Dracula movies
and the differences between them and the
similarities and the things that were
left out what was the name of that video
well it was James from Cinema
and he did well basically what he did
and I I have a hard time thinking
believing that he watched every Dracula
movie but he's like well I tried to
watch like all of the main ones you know
what I mean
um and he actually picked out the top
dozen that were kind of like the closest
to the book and then he did like it was
a long video it's like an hour or
something like that and he breaks down
like which ones are the most book
accurate and he lays them out side by
side and what happens in all of them
what's left out from the book and which
one is it's good I've watched it a bunch
of times and and what's funny is that
there isn't a single movie out there
that is exactly like the book no no no
you're gonna end up with three or four
movies that are close
but then those four movies are very
different from each other
yeah he's the closest one was a was one
that was made for the BBC in I think it
was in the 80s I think it was made for
TV yeah
um but yeah it was made for BBC that's
TV and um he said that was the most book
accurate and like the Francis Ford
Coppola one he said weirdly that one is
very book accurate but it also adds a
bunch of stuff he's like not so much
taking it away but I think that might be
the only one that has the character of
Quincy Morris in it because I don't even
remember if the BBC one has that hardly
anybody puts Quincy Morris in there
that's the Texan right yeah yeah which
is like super funny but I guess they're
just like well there's too many
characters so they were trying to kind
of like
most movies I see they're like leave
them out entirely or like put some of
his attributes like into another
character I guess but yeah there's that
um let's see slasher Fred said if you
guys ever watch that old classic show
Murder She Wrote which started the now
late Angela Lansbury there was an
episode where man is killed uh with a
stake through the heart
I don't think you know what what I feel
like I what I saw that a couple times
like with when I was over at my
grandma's house or something like that
and that just seems like a show that I
probably really like but I just never
got to do it I just never gotta do it
uh Slash red also said one of these days
you guys should watch and review
subspecies yeah I've been wanting to do
that for a while I like that movie
that's a vampire movie Louie saw that
video it says it's a very good video
yeah it's like I don't know why I find
that kind of stuff so fascinating I
really like
um videos like talking about the
differences between book and movie
adaptations that's why I tried I did
some for my scare Salon Channel I need
to do more though like I was thinking
about it today that I probably
yeah Louis said Francis Ford yeah that's
what I said Francis scored couple has
also had Quincy Morris I can't remember
if the BBC one that was actually the
most accurate had Quincy Morris or not
though because I haven't seen that one
but that was the one that he he did it
like like I said he watched all the
Dracula movies and he's like well some
of the ones that were like really wildly
different like he just discounted them
but he just picked like the top 12 that
were the closest and then he did it like
on a point system you know what I mean
like and he went by like scenes
characters blah blah and he laid out his
whole like um you know the reasons why
he chose certain things and stuff like
that and the BBC One was the top and
then I think the Coppola one was second
but he said that the Coppola one is book
accurate in a lot of ways but it adds a
bunch of [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah Zach said the Gary Oldman Dracula
is probably one of my top 10 movies ever
I know that's a that's such a great
movie I really like
he tried to make it like the book I
really like that he made it like with
all these old school like practical
effects like with the you know
marionette like but not marionettes but
like the shadow puppets and like the way
that it's all letters like they did like
that kind of like uh pistolary style and
all that kind of stuff I thought that
was really cool
um and you don't really see that all
that much you know what I mean it's kind
of like it was the same kind of thing
and we talked about this a little bit
when we were talking about
um uh Kenneth brana's uh Frankenstein is
that I really liked that they actually
tried to make that closer to the book
instead because most Frankenstein movies
don't have any of the stuff like that
happen in the Arctic or any of that like
the frame story you know what I mean
um so I kind of like that they had that
so it was like the most book accurate
but there was a bunch of other things in
there that uh were not book accurate so
you know uh Louis said is the BBC
version one with uh Louis Jordan yeah I
think it was that one actually
I think it was that one now that I'm
thinking about it
yeah he actually he made a great uh
vampire and then he was the villain in
swamp thing isn't that funny
slasher friend said uh Bram Stoker's
Dracula also pays uh an homage to the
original nosferati yeah that's right it
does and I've been I don't know I kind
of want to do nosferati one of these
days too
you know it's a slow it's slow movie
I've seen it remember I've seen it I
like silent movies though
you know what I mean it's really slow
well you know what we can do it if you
want to yeah one of these days I think I
like that Nosferatu that was a trip
[ __ ] kinsky that was some weird ass
[ __ ] yeah dude's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ]
I'm I keep telling you you should
probably see shadow of the vampire yeah
which is about I mean it's from the
2000s like it's from 2000 or 2001. um
and it has Willem Dafoe in it but it's
about the making of the original
Nosferatu except the guy Max Shrek that
plays is an actual vampire okay like
that's each one it's not yet it's not a
comedy necessarily but it's really
really good it's really good like John
Malkovich is in it and like it's really
good yeah but it's about that whole
experience except Max Shrek is really a
vampire yeah pops can't see Nosferatu I
wouldn't call it a great movie but he
does a great job as a [ __ ] Nosferatu
in it well he's always good as a creep
and yeah and he is kind of closer to
what's what was described in a lot of
the folklore that a vampire is more kind
of like a plague or a disease that's
showed up on you it's not some sexy sex
object [ __ ] he's nasty yeah that
was a later yeah and that's closer to
what more like a rat like a big human
looking rat which that's a stragoy looks
like a big human rat too you know
um that's why you know
see blood vessel that's a good strong
boy movie you'll see a lot you'll and
theoretically with the [ __ ] Starboy
reproductive [ __ ] Cycles how they can
do things stragoy could Pro could make a
thing like Dracula as a child
you know what I mean you could have a
child that was like that which might
explain where vampires came from but a
Starboy was drink blood but it wasn't a
vampire
not really it was more powerful than a
vampire
if you asked me
Jeff yard said hey guys I just want to
let you know that we tried out the
pumpkin spice cocktails they came out
really amazing but really strong yeah
um once we perfect the recipe I'll
gladly share it with you guys we should
probably I mean because tomorrow's
Halloween I'm gonna do like the whole
costume and everything like that maybe
we should like get some Halloween themed
Libations because I feel like we don't
have it I mean even if we just get some
more videos we have to go get it tonight
I guess we could do it tomorrow yeah we
could go tomorrow I might have time
tomorrow to go get something it won't
take that long that's true I mean if
we're just going up to yeah Louie said
the Frank langella version is also very
good even though it's all over the place
yeah I always had a a soft spot in my
heart for that one because I think that
might have been the first version of
Dracula that I saw
I think I saw that one because that came
out in 1979 when I was you know seven
years old so I think that was the first
one I saw I saw that one before Bella
Lugosi before Christopher Lee I saw it
before any of the other Draculas
uh Kessler Garcia says uh Jim Carrey
dancing rocks yeah it's like he
was the dance-off scene he wasn't you
really kind of get he's pretty
restrained in this you don't get because
you know how and I don't usually like
Jim Carrey's like roll over this like
the mask and all that kind of stuff like
I don't too much gonna have cocaine man
yeah it's just it's too much it's too
much
um now when he does more subdued roles
um like Eternal Sunshine in a Spotless
Mind which is one of my favorite movies
of all time he's great he's [ __ ]
great in that
um because he's just it's more like a
serious role you know what I mean and
he's really good in it but in this one
he's pretty subdued in this one too like
he does like a couple little goofy
things but nothing like over the top but
that dancing that he does you can see
that kind of lick he's all like [ __ ]
rubbery and [ __ ] so you can see a little
bit of that but he's not like
so we have a really good stand Jim
Carrey that's what I mean I can yeah
it's not really my thing but like I said
his comedy isn't really my thing but
Winnie but when he's serious like in a
serious role like a Truman Show like he
was great in that too like when he's
does a serious role he's actually really
really good like a lot of comedians yeah
I mean there's only one other comedian
that came close to him and being
obnoxious and that was early Robin
Williams was so [ __ ] obnoxious man
that was another cocaine hit but that
dude was so [ __ ] great in a in a
serious roles [ __ ] like one hour
photo that's that was a [ __ ]
Masterpiece man there's he was in
another one called insomnia that you
might that you've never seen it yeah
that you might like I saw in the theater
it was I remember it being really good
but I haven't seen it for a long time
yeah uh Louis said I think nosferati was
a Dracula ripoff uh yes it is yeah they
actually yeah they got sued actually
nosferati were lucky that it actually
exists because they ordered all the
copies destroyed yeah I only want to
survive uh and only one survived and
that's you know what they what they've
uh you know copied from that Master yeah
because it's the same story they just
changed all the names trying to be slick
trying to avoid copyright to try to
avoid copyright but I mean Bram Stoker
was dead by then but his widow was still
alive yeah and she was like uh that's
the same story you just changed all the
names another another [ __ ] weird
movie uh uh story is the Phantom of the
Opera yeah nobody really knows what the
what the real original Phantom of the
Opera movie was because that movie came
out
during a time they were transitioning
from Silent into talkies
and they were like four or five
different silent versions and then when
they went to the talkies they changed
[ __ ] up and then there was like seven or
eight different versions of The Talky
version
there's footage missing or added or
whatever and all this [ __ ] got [ __ ]
lost over time and a lot of them were
destroyed
and I think there's four or five
different versions of Phantom of the
Opera and none of them are no form are
exactly the same and there's stuff
missing yeah and there's uh a scene
where a guy comes out and [ __ ] talks
to the [ __ ] audience it comes out of
a cave and says something to the
audience for a few seconds but there's
no audio there and it was some kind of a
monologue and they don't know what that
guy was supposed to say and that that
one's just a mess the original they
colorized it and when they did that they
[ __ ] up a bunch of [ __ ]
nobody really knows what Phantom of the
Opera the original Phantom of the Opera
was
the movie
here because I kind of feel like and
this kind of makes me sad but it's like
a lot of movies that came out in the
silent era that they know existed
because they still have like posters or
like people talked about them like from
back then and they are lost forever I
mean a lot of it I kind of feel like
well one silver nitrate stock was
probably like the main thing which is
very flammable in case you didn't know
so uh you know a lot of them were lost
in fires and things like that but I
think too it was just kind of like they
didn't really see I guess because film
was sort of like a new medium they
didn't really see it as an art form per
se yeah it was disposed like widely yeah
it wasn't per it wasn't it was
disposable it wasn't valuable to them it
was just something you made up that year
that month to make make some money and
then you replaced it with another one
they never were going to Play It Again
weird when you think about it it is
weird then they started preserving them
decades later but a lot of the [ __ ] had
deteriorated
but Phantom of the Opera was [ __ ]
just butchered over and over again
re-edited and re-edited and scenes
re-shot and put back in there they don't
know what what it originally was
got four or five different versions of
it they're all different yeah and
they're all Originals they're all from
that same company just kept
working on it and showing it working on
it and editing it like a traveling stage
act really just happened to be on film
weird I watched It's famous yeah they're
so famous clips of it you know [ __ ]
what was it was it Lon Chaney
to do the play that yeah a lot of famous
scenes from it
but they have those scenes but they
don't have the whole movie or or at
least the original
shit's missing and [ __ ] that other
shit's been added yeah and Louie says uh
mentions London after midnight which is
another movie that was lost they have
stills from it which look great and
scary but no shoe says is ravenous a
sort of vampire movie uh no ravenous is
actually a wendigo movie
um sort of it actually kind of goes with
uh it's like a cannibal it's more like a
cannibal but it's a wendigo it's a
wendigo it's really good if you haven't
seen it but yeah it's not a vampire
movie it's when it goes or a wendigo
um let's see wait
Zach says insomnia which I just
mentioned before is actually a remake of
a Norwegian movie from the 90s starring
stolen Skarsgard which is kind of itself
a ripoff of seven yeah I remember it
being kind of like seven I didn't know
London after midnight was a vampire
movie it was lost that's what yeah it's
yeah it's gone they know it existed like
I said because they have Stills and they
have like people talking about it it
looks good it looks cool like from The
Stills but nobody knows the screenplay
or the oh I don't know you know nothing
exists from that I don't know I'd have
to look into it that might be an
interesting show actually because I'm
fascinated by like all because I love
silent movies and it's like I'm really
fascinated by the ones that they don't
because there's a [ __ ] time that they
know existed but you know they're
they're lost and they don't know I mean
they might be copies around somewhere
but they haven't found them
um I watched actually I watched uh the a
1910 version of Frankenstein that Thomas
Edison made
slasher Fred said London after midnight
was remade in a 1935 film called uh Mark
of the vampire yeah yeah and do they do
they know that that was an accurate
remake
because then you could if you see that I
mean have you basically seen London
after midnight
be nice to know yeah I'll have to go
look at the Stills I've never that's
like one of the most famous like lost
horror movies from that era but
they must have in general knew what the
movie was in order to remake it
yeah that's the thing it's like I'm sure
that you know people wrote about the
movie or you know remember the movie or
remembered it or whatever yeah and if
somebody wrote it down then yeah
yeah Louis said uh yeah it was remade
but I hear it's nowhere near as good as
the original
Zach says people are still looking for a
five hour cut of the silent movie agreed
does it was that Eric fosterheim uh that
was supposedly the best movie ever made
uh directed by the guy who plays the
butler in Sunset Boulevard yeah
they're gonna talk about uh Robert
Englund was a good Phantom of the Opera
that's right he did do a version didn't
he I don't remember if I saw it though I
want to say that I saw it but maybe I
didn't maybe I just saw like stills from
it I think Dario Argento made a version
too but I didn't love it ozia was in it
of course but I like her I like her but
I just reviewed Dario's new movie the
other day dark glasses it was like
it was I but not that great sadly but I
didn't expect it to be great so I wasn't
really all that disappointed look at
what that [ __ ] look at what that cat did
yeah God she just tore that [ __ ] out
tearing up by Kurt Vonnegut yeah and she
thinks it's funny this runs away but
like I said that's I mean that book is
so old I think I bought it at a thrift
store for a dollar like 20 25 years ago
but see that's what I know that she does
that when she wants attention she goes
and like starts pulling things out of
shells things out of the shelves and
like um you know pulling the pages out
of books and whatnot so that's like
we're all like my shitty old well I
guess boring being a cat
hahaha
what should we like send her to school
yeah I guess boring me together give her
like some like some math books or some
novels to read or something like that
all right so um are we finished with the
review uh review on this I guess so I
guess so you didn't you seem kind of
cranky I don't want to talk about it
why do you think it was a great movie I
just I didn't think it was a great movie
I wasn't really amused with it I hadn't
seen it before the top it was definitely
top it's very very 80s maybe in the
mental frame of mind for that and I'm
just gonna oh [ __ ] it's one of these
well like I said I was kind of like I
wasn't drunk but I was kind of like a
little bit I was really sleepy and I was
like really and I was a little bit
buzzed and I was just kind of like well
it's like this will be an easy one
because it's Halloween themed it's like
I've seen it a bunch of times real corny
humor so yeah I mean it's and it's dated
in a lot of ways too like in the same
way that like you know a lot of 80s
comedies are very dated yeah you know
what I mean
um like I said there's there's a lot of
uh a lot of gay jokes and stuff like
that which kind of wouldn't fly nowadays
but you know
probably gay dudes wrote it
I don't know I don't know I don't know
who wrote it yeah it's funny because the
Wikipedia page I kind of feel like it
didn't um like it I don't think it did
all that good of business when it came
out but it's one of those movies that
kind of became a cult classic somebody
mentioned uh my best friend is a vampire
I remember really liking that one too
but I haven't seen that one in a long
time either maybe I'll get around to
that one as well I saw that a bunch of
times but I didn't see it as many times
as this
but the funny thing one one of the funny
things about this was that I liked when
Jim Carrey was like first starting to
get turned into a vampire and he goes to
you know he's at the in the lunch line
like at school or whatever and they're
doing burgers and uh you know they give
him one that's like not very written
he's just like can I have one of those
uncooked ones back there and I'm like
yeah see that's kind of what I was doing
I didn't like have the uncooked one but
I'd be like just gonna go okay and then
give it to me then it's good
uh slasher Fred said if you guys ever
see the 1948 comedy classic Abbott and
Costello Meet Frankenstein there's a
vampire goof in the scene where Dracula
bites uh Sandra if you look closely you
can see his reflection yeah I don't
think I've I don't know if I've seen any
of the Abbott and Costello like monster
movies like when they were doing like
the Monster Mash like later stuff with
uh Godzilla maybe I should probably
watch those I feel like that's a gap in
my movie watching
uh Gerard Butler also played The Phantom
of the Opera in the early 2000s and he
played Dracula I feel I feel like I saw
his Phantom of the Opera where how the
[ __ ] did I see that
hmm maybe like I said maybe somebody
loaned it to me
I feel like somebody probably loaned it
to me
Zach said whoever uh thought a writer is
great as Kurt Vonnegut could come from a
place as boring as Indiana well that's
probably why I mean all that imagination
yeah you had you had to like make up
your boring you had to make up your own
fun
I love Kurt Vonnegut I really do I think
the Sirens of Titan is probably my
favorite but the one that she the one
that she tore up I don't think I have
Sirens of Titan the one she tore up is
uh God bless you Mr rosewater but like I
said I've had that one for a million
years I bought it at a thrift store a
long time ago
and yeah
she just you guys can't see it but it's
just like it's a total paper disaster
over there she's just she was letting us
know that she was really not happy that
we turned the ceiling fan on she was
just very very upset and yelling if you
weren't here at the beginning and we
couldn't even like talk because she was
yelling so much but yeah she wanted to
be on the show all right so we're gonna
wrap it up I guess because I'm kind of
sleepy from
last night I didn't drink all that much
last night it's just I didn't really get
much sleep because
you know when I got home I was just kind
of like well I gotta take off these damn
fingernails and that took a really long
time and then it took me a really long
time to get the contact lenses back out
because I'm not used to wearing contact
lenses so it was really I'm sitting
there going oh my God I can't leave
these in my [ __ ] eyes and so it was
like ages and I was like come on and I'm
like I couldn't get him out and so it
took forever so I don't think I fell
asleep until like 4 30 and then I woke
up at like 8 30. so you know I'm a
little bit sleepy but that's all all
right so tomorrow is Halloween
so I'm gonna do my costume that I did
last night that was a big hit by the way
uh you know everybody thought it looked
really awesome everybody wanted their
picture taken with me and [ __ ] like that
uh so I'm not gonna show any of the
pictures yet though because I don't want
to ruin the surprise but yeah I'm gonna
do the costume again tomorrow and we'll
probably talk about we're gonna talk
about haunting I kind of feel like maybe
we should do like a haunting Side Tracks
mashup because it's Halloween we should
do like a Halloween special you know
what I'm saying so maybe we should talk
about we were gonna talk about that
mummy episode
which maybe we'll do that but we'll
we'll look at what we got and see if we
can come up with something better but if
not we'll do the mommy one because that
one's like super funny
uh Zach said I want to go out for
Halloween but I got to go to bed early
for work yeah it kind of sucks for like
Halloween the actual Halloween's on a
Monday when's the show going to start
tomorrow
six
you do realize that you're gonna be
people yeah I know I know okay I know
I mean I don't know we'll we'll figure
something out I guess okay
unless you want to do it later I'd
probably be best to do it either later
or earlier or earlier
I mean I don't know multiple things
probably best to do it earlier
okay
yeah maybe we should because then we get
the show out of the way
because they're going to be
trick-or-treating too yeah well it
depends on where you are on the planet
at different time zones that's what I'm
saying but um I don't know we'll work
something out and then we'll I'll
announce it like because
this the show as we're streaming in this
time zone will be pretty much in the
thicket of when all those [ __ ] kids
are gonna start knocking right yeah and
then we'll have time right so that means
I'm gonna be getting up and going down
that getting up and going down getting
up and going down every [ __ ] five
minutes yeah all right so it
this is the first time in this house
well we did that last year
and it was what
I think we did end the show didn't we
I don't remember I don't remember if we
I don't know if we actually if we didn't
stream on actually I don't think I had
Halloween stuff no I did because I
already had a Halloween stuff we'll
worry about it later yeah like I said
we'll worry about it later we're gonna
have to change the time I think yeah we
might have to change the time just we
might like yeah we might do it earlier
might be a better thing to do
yeah but yeah that way you can go hand
out some candy in your costume yeah
that's true because yeah if I'm gonna
get all that effort yeah we went to
downtown Sanford last night like
Saturday night and that place was
[ __ ] insane we thought we were gonna
have to come back home because we
couldn't find a place to park yeah then
we finally we drove around and drove
around and drove around and finally we
found a place to park and then like we
went to mannequins and it's like it was
so [ __ ] packed in there like you
could barely move couldn't dance hardly
you couldn't dance because it's like I
mean it was still it was still fun
because like everybody and we hung out
like back on the um the patio most of
the night because that wasn't quite as
crowded but man the Latino dudes were
[ __ ] freaking out over my [ __ ]
costume man
screaming to me from across the street
about Batman and [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] yelling back and Danny
Trejo's voice
laughs
[Laughter]
it was fun though we had we ended up
having a good time it was like like I
said it was kind of my costume took a
long time to do so we didn't actually
get down there until what was it quarter
to ten or something like that and then
like we got down there and the they were
doing a street festival like early on in
the night so part of the street was like
closed off in front of mannequins but
then like we couldn't find a place to
park there was millions of people like
walking around and [ __ ] like that but
eventually we found a place and it's
like it but yeah the club was [ __ ]
packed yeah but it was just I mean still
like I said you couldn't dance because
there was no room but it was fun like
seeing everybody's costumes and [ __ ]
yeah everybody want to take pictures
with Jim
yeah well like I said I was kind of that
the costume came out better than I
expected like because I always kind of
think I I had it in my mind like how it
was gonna come out I was like I'm pretty
sure it's gonna look but see [ __ ] never
works out like the way that I think it's
going to like and I'm always kind of
like oh I'm gonna do this that and the
other but then I do it and I'm like okay
that looks stupid but this time I was
like oh my God it actually works that's
amazing and you know
Zach says when I'm at the gay bar I'm
always hanging out in the back because
you can actually have a conversation out
there it's out of the system that place
can liquefy your organs yeah that's the
thing and and the music you know they
have at mannequins they have like you
know they have the Paul vein he's DJs
inside and then um
uh our friend DJ Spooky Puffs uh Carey
she DJ's outside and uh like out on the
patio and last night I think the music
was louder last night than usual because
man I couldn't hear a [ __ ] word
anybody was saying it's like when I was
like talking to people I had to like
scream at them and you know but it was
like I said it was still fun we saw some
good costumes although we saw a bunch of
people who also didn't bother either
which I was kind of like okay
so you're just asked me when VA money
comes in VA money will come in
tomorrow at midnight
or tonight at midnight no no tomorrow at
midnight tomorrow at midnight just 31
days
that's right I forgot yeah
I forgot
all right so we're gonna wrap it up
we'll discuss like what time we want to
do the show tomorrow
uh because I'm gonna have to know like
ahead of time because you know my
costume needs several hours of
preparation so I'm gonna have to like uh
start getting ready like whatever early
so but we'll let you guys know what
we're gonna talk about and
what time it's going to be and [ __ ] like
that I would do it early that's probably
like a better idea because I was kind of
thinking about them do the Halloween
thing and then we shut it down then we
get and we come back at a decent hour
kind of deal yeah that's true all right
so uh yeah hopefully you guys can join
us whatever we decide to do this [ __ ]
tomorrow
three or four
four probably
that's kind of yeah that's kind of what
I was thinking for and then it'll be
over by six and then that's that's about
the time that they're I think it gets
dark around six some six thirty yeah
something like so that's what I would do
I'd start well it's seven o'clock right
now is it dark yet
I can't really see yeah I get well no
it's not completely no it's not it's not
completely dark because they start when
it's dark so yeah maybe we should start
at four or like Eastern
maybe that would be a better idea four
or five yeah four probably and then that
way you know we don't have to worry
about like rushing and stuff and then if
like one or two people come they'd be
like little no big deal no big deal yeah
all right so we'll see you guys tomorrow
like I said I'll make an announcement
and uh have a good Halloween Eve and
we'll see you guys again tomorrow bye